[Music]
cyril jr
[Applause]
dini
[Music]
cyril jr dim
[Applause]
thank you contest chair you're welcome
i
love
that the contest chair sounds more
zimbabwean than i do
in zimbabwe we speak shona
and in this beautiful language we have a
very important word that i'd like to
share with you today
in shona we say
n
d
i n i
try it
beautiful
it means
this
is me
in my language we have one word for this
very important phrase
this
is me
this word is special for me now but
growing up i wasn't always comfortable
with who i was
you see even though i grew up in
zimbabwe my middle name was a long
winding
complicated nigerian name
because my father whom i never knew
was
nigerian now yes
i may know a nigerian prince or two
but back then
i didn't want a nigerian name
i wanted a cool name
like martin luther king jr
or contest chair
the other kids would make fun of me
they said my name was useful
as a password
they called my middle name memorably
forgettable
they said my middle name
was a curse
from black magic
i hated my
name have you ever hated something about
yourself
i would argue with mom i would be so mad
at her you gave me this name you did
this to me and now everybody makes fun
of me because i'm
different and my mom would look at me
and say but son
that name is who you are
it's special
you know your middle name means that
what god has done
no man can change
and i said mom
man has changed many things okay look at
chihuahuas
that used to be a wolf
[Laughter]
i'm pretty sure i can change my name
and i did
as soon as i turned 18 i had my middle
name removed from all my documents
it became my best kept secret
and i have not said that name once ever
since
before i knew it it was 2018 and i'd
landed in college not in zimbabwe not
even in africa but in the heart of
eastern europe
it was clear
who grew up in the snow
and who grew up in the sand
[Music]
i had never been this different before
the fly in the milk
it felt like i had taken one step
forward and ten steps
backwards but then i met nick
another fly in the milk but from congo
he's got the
african boy swag you know low deep voice
speaks very slowly
he's like mufasa but in slow motion
we're in the library one day and nick
drops his id
and like a good friend i pick it up and
proceed to read it
out loud
including his full name
nicholas rollin sweeney bitumi
i say dude
let's say your name three times and see
what happens
[Laughter]
but i knew exactly how those words must
have felt
but nick was ready
i have never
met anybody
with my name
it was a gift from my grandfather
and i
like it
and we laughed
and we got kicked out of the library
[Music]
but in my heart
i was 18 again
seeing in nick
what i didn't have for myself
acceptance
and for the first time i started looking
around and i realized we're all
different
even nick was different
but he wasn't just different he was
special
because he accepted himself
and for the first time in a long time i
wanted to accept myself too i looked
myself in the mirror and said in
dna this
this is me
i know that many of you out there at
some point in your life have felt
uncomfortable being who you are
maybe it was your name maybe it was the
family you came from
maybe it was the school you went to
maybe you were tall maybe you were short
maybe you have wrinkles freckles maybe
you have scars i know that some of you
out there know what it is to be
different
and even if you don't feel it i'm sure
you know somebody who does
you are
beautifully
you
the only
and no man
can change that
so let me invite you to make this very
important word a part of your language
dini
this is me
for my friends here in nashville and the
thousands watching from home say it with
me this is me
dini
beautiful
i haven't had the courage
to officially reclaim my name
but here today
i think we can make a step in the right
direction
i was born
cyril
jr
and this is me
dining
[Applause]
you